a few interesting posts on the david
pakman show subreddit i i invite you to
join us there
um respectful political discussion with
just
27 000 of our closest friends in the
audience
you can go to davidpakman.com reddit
um a very interesting post about what if
what happened on january 6th had
happened
when barack obama had been president and
what if it was 2012 and
obama had lost to mitt romney but
insisted he actually won
and spent months promoting on twitter
and facebook that he won
and that mitt romney had stolen the
election and then on the day when the
electoral college votes were being
counted
barack obama went to a rally and told
antifa
and black lives matter people let's go
to the capitol
and then they did and they broke into
the capitol
and a police officer died do you think
that the reactions would have been the
same from republicans what do you think
we would be seeing on fox news what do
you think we would be seeing
from the standpoint of of the republican
party
on the floors of the house and the
senate give me a break guys you need
only imagine that scenario to see the
level of hypocrisy
uh and dishonesty and immorality that we
are seeing
from republicans today very very good
post also an interesting question from a
user who goes by the name
fred osaurus on our subreddit
who says will trump divulge state
secrets when he's out of office i'm
worried of the national security risk
that trump will represent when out of
office
because even if he can be removed from
the office he surely has state secrets
in his head that obviously can't be
removed
i'm surprised he hasn't spilled already
but i'm wondering if any of you think he
will use his knowledge of state secrets
as a bargaining chip with his cronies
or who knows i wouldn't be surprised if
the russians approach him undercover or
not
and try to get him to divulge some of
the things that would be useful to
them i i don't actually think so and
there's a couple things number one and
this was actually mentioned in the
comments trump hasn't been reading his
uh presidential daily briefings for a
long time he hasn't even been receiving
the morally for a long time
so trump knows way fewer state secrets
than most presidents because he's not
been paying attention for a very long
time and he doesn't really care
number two i don't actually think trump
would would do something like
selling state secrets for cash or
anything like that i
i don't think that he would be morally
against it i just don't think that it
would end up being put together
but i do think it's quite plausible that
in order to brag
trump will say things to people he's not
supposed to be saying things to
um often with trump much of his behavior
comes out of incompetence or narcissism
rather than out of malice although
there's no shortage of malice
for for sure but let me know what you
think about that and join the discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60
000 masks to healthcare institutions
they're an
excellent company shipping is just five
bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david